welcome back to google developers weekly
for January 28th 2014 I'm Louis gray and
this is our highlight reel of what's
happening in the world of Google
developers on the set and off starting
the week's festivities we head to London
where mano marks invites gde Steven gray
no relation so far as I'm aware to show
us how he added ground overlays and
whether using the Maps SDK for iOS
Steve's app uses a tile overlay to tone
down the map styling and remove map
labels giving a nice and clean
background for weather data but the Maps
team wasn't done with a single episode
here on GDL Paul saxman covered the
basics of adding markers to your map
using the Google Maps Android API v2 so
don't miss either show geo developers we
then head up the road from our main
campus to the Google San Francisco
office where Chrome guru Peter lubbers
hosted the San Francisco html5 user
group this week's event focused on WebGL
Peter also put on a microphone to be
part of the second office hour session
for Udacity CS 256 joining chris wilson
and Sean Bennett to tackle questions
around lessons four and five in this
fast-paced mobile web development course
we record every single one so you never
fall behind we then invited open source
maven cat Allman to the studio who
interviewed Googler Jeremy Allison to
talk on the Samba project the standard
Windows interoperability suite of
programs for linux and unix and our
studios aren't open to just Googlers
mamie Rheingold interviewed for young
coding members of DIY org and online
community for kids to learn skills
discover cool projects and meet other
awesome kids hear how they learn to code
and get inspired and up in Seattle where
they know just a thing or two about
clouds laurence maroney and Brian Dorsey
of the cloud platform team took
questions on what cloud means to
customers and how Google offering to get
even better from New York Ibrahim
Ulukaya took a look at best practices
for YouTube API is on iOS including
YouTube direct Lite for iOS then Amy
quiz be an era clicked Aslaug took the
time to walk through the new google
mobile ads features in Google Play
services and explained how to migrate
away from the standalone AdMob SDK the
google glass team took some time
recently to experiment with games on
glass the games are quick and fun and we
hope they inspire our glass developers
to start their own projects go to govt
co / glass mini games to find out more
and dark flight school is coming soon
you can learn dart at one of these
awesome events taking place around the
globe you'll learn dart and get to
explore great frameworks like polymer an
angular go to dartlang.org and search
for flight school to sign up now and
every year Google Code in fines amazing
teenage programmers from around the
world and awards them afford a trip to
Google in Mountain View this year's 20
winners have been announced and you can
read about them on our blog at Google
developers blogspot com congratulations
to the 20 winners and the hundreds more
who entered and to make sure that you
never miss a thing from the world of
google developers subscribe to google
developers on youtube and check out the
gdl schedule at
developers.google.com/live I'm Louis
gray and I'll see you in the studio